this is the place I'll go down to get  the crystal Sonic and I will go get the  crystal knuckles and Tails you stay back  and taste the villages attacked again  put you in charge  I say tails in I will stay back and  protect the village and you and Sonic  take the elevator you win this round  knuckles Amy let's go  Wow what is this place  how do you just keep appearing out of  nowhere because I am awesome and I fit  into vents I was created here programmed  here  hey the crystal it's right there so  close it's right by the entrance that  never happens  I think I can make it up there I knew it  wasn't gonna be easy  you'll never just get the prize ah  always a fight nice Sonic  I guess a little bite before we get the  crystal isn't so bad okay  you need better minions Eggman  yeah